So in the last lesson,
you saw this example network.
Hosts A and
B are attached to fast networks, but
the link between them is slow.
If one of them tried to send to
the other at the speed of the local fast
network, they'd congest
the link between them.
The router would have to drop traffic
in order to get anything through.
And TCP is smart enough to do slow start
to avoid congesting
intermediate network links.
But here's a more realistic
example of a network.
Here we have some
servers in a data center
with an internal network that's
very fast, a 10Gbit ethernet.
And the data center network
is attached to the Internet
with a link that's pretty fast too,
1 Gbit.
And here are all the users.
There are really a lot of users,
each of whom have internet connections
that are slow by comparison.
Now the capacity of a network link or
of a multilink path to carry data
in terms of bits per
second is its bandwidth.
And we can talk about the bandwidth of
a link here, but we can also talk about
the bandwidth available from this user
to this server across multiple links.
Now that's generally going to be
the minimum of the bandwidths of
those links.
If your server network is very fast,
that means that your servers can talk
to each other at that high speed.
But if your users' home networks are
very slow, upgrading your server network
will probably not have any effect
on the speed that your users see.
This may seem obvious but this concept
of a limiting factor turns out to be
really important in a lot of
server administration situations.
But if you have a large number of
simultaneous users, each of whom was on
a slow network, all of those slows
may add up to more than a fast.
That's one reason server networks
are typically a lot faster than end
user networks.
And this has some pretty
significant implications.
If you know how much traffic
a typical user makes and
you know how many
simultaneous users you have,
you can tell how fast this
connection needs to be.
Or on the scary side of things,
if all of these users started hitting
your service as hard as they could,
you could tell how fat this pipe
would have to be in order to hold up.